oh your little podcast is that a hobby
[Music]
thanks for watching ati it is brought to
you by black rifle coffee all right hey
i'm natalie cuomo i'm here to answer the
internet is sex with conjoined twins a
threesome
absolutely yes it only is a threesome if
you have two sets of genitals there
i think you know it's one head
because then it's like one person one
brain if you can put your part if you
can
use both holes like if you can put it in
oh if you can
if you can receive a [ __ ] and finger
at the same time it's a threesome wait i
can do that with a regular person yeah
but there are two they're two brains and
two hearts
if they can talk about it later it's a
threesome
do you think there are more porn stars
or murderers in the world i'd say
they're definitely more murderers than
legitimate porn stars
but if you add in just the only fans
everyone has an only fans my grandma has
an only fan
what classifies as a murderer i don't
know killing someone if i hit you with
my car and kill you i killed you i
murdered you no if i wanted to but it
was an accident yeah i still murdered
you
this is the problem that's an accident
well what would my what would your
parents say they would say that i
murdered you if you could get access to
one person's phone and look at all their
[ __ ] who would it be is it for personal
reasons or professional reasons you know
what would be professional professional
would be like
blackmailing someone that has power i
honestly like if i'm hooking up with
someone or dating someone i do not want
to see their phone i don't want to know
my feeling is this once you look through
someone else's phone the relationship's
over there's no trust
i've gone through many a guy's phone
am i with them today if you could wipe
one group of people off the earth who
would it be there are a lot of people
that write really mean things on my tick
tocks i don't want them here anymore it
really gets it's just like
haters it gets it really gets to me
would you rather a get paid one million
a year
but have to work ridiculous hours get a
hundred thousand dollars a year for
doing nothing i would say a million
dollars a year
i like to work i like to work
you can just do anything you want like
you don't have to work you can have a
hobby and just make 100 a year yeah but
it's so insulting what if i was like oh
your little podcast is that a hobby
that's literally what my boss says to me
would you rather lose your ability to
taste food or to feel sex so i'm on
antidepressants and i don't feel sex
[Laughter]
who is the one person in the world you
would least want to bang your
significant other someone hotter than me
a person i know who they could develop
an emotional relationship with
someone who could replace me
if you had to watch your biggest enemy
[ __ ] the guy of your dreams in order for
you to marry him would you do it
no no no no i actually genuinely could
not do it that is disgusting and uh i'm
a jealous [ __ ] so no would you rather
sit down with your parents and watch
every sexual encounter you've ever had
or sit by yourself to watch a sex tape
of the night they conceived you honestly
i've never seen my parents show
affection towards one another
so i'll go with that one
if you are an american
and you're not drinking black rifle
coffee
you're not an american anymore that's a
rule you want to know why because it was
founded by members of our united states
armed forces they were over there in the
suck over there in the desert so hungry
and thirsty for coffee because you
mostly drink it you don't eat it so
thirsty for coffee that evan evan haffer
he was he was reorganizing trucks he was
taking trucks and he was turning them
into coffee grinders and coffee makers
because he loves coffee that much that
shows in the taste of black rifle coffee
they import their beans from all over
the world they brew them they roast them
right here in america the best way to
join to do join the to drink black rifle
coffee is to join the black rifle
monthly coffee cup you pick your roast
you pick your amount you get it
delivered to your door every month go to
blackrifle.com slash bar stool and get a
delivery don't use promo code barstool
as well blackrifle.com bar stool use
code barstool get it delivered to your
door today
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon